me oyen escuchando
pues si me oyen y si me escuchan creo
que el objetivo fundamental de la
plática de hoy ya habrá tenido lugar
porque de eso se trata de oír y de
escuchar es exactamente lo que quería
compartir con todos ustedes hoy aquí y
ahora
como músico como compositor como
director de artista me dedico a escuchar
y médico escuchar todos los días y
médico escuchar desde hace
aquí entraría mi segunda pregunta que
tendría para ustedes desde cuando
escuchamos
sabemos que el oído es el primer sentido
que se forma
sabemos de hecho que escuchamos antes de
nacer
dicen los que saben que aproximadamente
a las 14 16 semanas de gestación
comenzamos a realizar a relacionarnos
con el sonido reaccionamos a ese sonido
la respuesta al habla bien un poco más
tarde
respuesta al habla mientras dicen que
aproximadamente sobre las 24 semanas
y la respuesta al sonido es ciertamente
temprana así escuchamos el corazón de
nuestra mamá
su respiración su voz
flujos y reflujos maravillosos de su
organismo y comenzamos a relacionarnos
por primera vez con la vida extrauterina
a través del sonido comienza a aparecer
por primera vez la música
así pues
y comenzamos a relacionarnos con ese
sonido incluso antes si me permiten de
conocer el aire que respiramos después
o puesto en otros términos y si me lo
permiten la música existe antes de
nuestra vida en la tierra
mientras habitamos el líquido amniótico
conocemos la realidad acústica
lógicamente más grave más distante y a
menor volumen de lo que realmente es
escuchamos como una suerte de oleaje una
especie de murmullo que nos permite
identificar cada alteración de este
oleaje de ese murmullo de esa textura
general de sonido como un acontecimiento
entre esos acontecimientos la voz y por
supuesto la música
creo que estaremos de acuerdo en la
importancia que va adquiriendo la música
al menos en las etapas pre terrestres
si me permiten
en el momento dichoso de nuestros papás
comienzan a elegir nombres para nosotros
porque acaban de enterarse de nuestro
sexo ese momento divertido es el momento
verdaderamente familiar en ese momento
está precedido de largas horas de
escucha está precedido de largas obras
de música porque la música existe antes
que el sexo la música existirá
mucho antes de la posibilidad de ser
nombrados antes del habla y como les
comentaba antes del aire que respiramos
así pues en el momento en el momento que
vivimos en ese líquido amniótico como
les contaba la percepción acústica
tendrá sus propias reglas en el momento
del parto en el momento del parto
pasaremos de una manera más o menos
dramática del
el entorno acústico acuoso
lógicamente el aéreo
los sentidos comenzarán a funcionar
comenzaremos a conocer por los sentidos
pero comenzaremos a reconocer por el
oído comenzamos a segundo ser una
realidad que habíamos de una manera u
otra experimentado con la integración
después del parto después del grito
después del llanto posterior
reconoceremos a nuestra madre por su voz
ahora seré mucho más presente será mucho
más fuerte será mucho más aguda pero
sabemos que si la voz de nuestra mamá
y lo sabremos porque ese es el sonido
que llevamos muchos meses muchas semanas
escuchando
si se dan cuenta conoceremos y
reconoceremos mejor dicho en nuestra
madre
por la longitud de sus palabras por el
perfil melódico
de sus frases y por el ritmo de su habla
y así a partir de ese momento como les
decía conoceremos los sentidos a partir
del parto comienzan a conocer es de todo
el oído que comienza a reconocer de una
manera u otra lo que ya como les decía
habíamos experimentado así pues nos
dedicamos a oír desde el momento que nos
hemos hasta la muerte
de hecho decías jacques attali que sólo
la muerte es silenciosa
y se dan cuenta
nos dedicamos a abrir no solo hasta el
momento de la muerte sino una parte nos
dedicamos inevitablemente oír y diego
inevitablemente porque no hay manera de
poder detener la audición
no existen párpados no existe ningún
sistema que nos por que nos detenga a
escuchar somos escuchas de tiempo
completo
en ese sentido ese es el verdadero gozo
de la música el verdadero gozo del
sonido del verdadero gozo de la exclusa
pero por otra parte es el castigo no
podemos dejar de oír
los que me conocen saben que son que soy
un gran perdedor de café poco antes de
que llegara la práctica y por tratar de
organizar un par de ideas es decir para
reparar en algún lugar y tomarme una
taza de café solo expresó
por supuesto llegué al lugar y me
preguntaron si lo quería normal si lo
quería descafeinado alto grande con
leche cortado o doble con algunos de los
incontables tipos de de leche que tenían
y me di cuenta que no me di cuenta que
lo que quería comida no podía tenerlo
quería un café solo y sin música sin esa
música que desafortunadamente estaba
escuchando en el café
pedí muy amablemente que si podían bajar
la que estaba preparando y me dijeron
que por supuesto que no
que la música funciona muy bien que los
clientes los clientes están muy
contentos con ella y que tampoco molesta
tanto y por supuesto en la bajaron y le
quitaron
así es es decir ese es el gozo y por eso
les decía es el castigo de la música no
podemos dejar de oír al menos aquello
que no queremos escuchar si admitimos
esa importancia la importancia que lo
que escuchamos no creen que podríamos
un poco menos condescendientes con la
música que escuchamos ser un poco más
críticos por lo menos porque en cafés
restaurantes odontólogos elevadores
espacios públicos centros comerciales
escucho música que no quiero escuchar
si los derechos acústicos existieran si
semejante cosa existiera no creo que
podríamos ser un poco más críticos
incluso exigir nuestros derechos
acústicos
pero al principio les decía que sí que
me dedico profesionalmente a escuchar es
a eso a lo que a lo que me dedico
generalmente cuando alguien un director
de orquesta una directora de orquesta de
lo primero preguntan para qué sirven
todos dos gestos extraños que hacen no
todo el mundo está tocando cuando llegó
una orquesta de los instrumentos y el
director de directoras en una serie de
gestos extrañísimos no y eso para qué
sirve pues a reservas de lo que
generalmente se conteste un director se
dedica a escuchar eso lo que hace
cuando abro una partitura comienzo a
generar una primera imagen acústica en
mi cabeza a través de horas de estudio
aunque no lo crean un director se dedica
fundamentalmente a estudiar o al menos
eso lo que me gustaría creer a través de
ahora este estudio lo que consigue el
director es ir perfilando ir mejorando
esa imagen acústica que quizás el
compositor haya querido expresar
así
se dedica básicamente a generar a
traducir a una manera acústica aquello
que gráficamente el compositor había
querido expresar por otra parte los
directores digamos al ensayo con las
maestras de los maestros de la orquesta
escucharemos nos escucharemos y
tomaremos juntos decisiones por tratar
de conseguir que esa traducción de lo
textual a lo acústico sea lo mejor
posible por lo menos tratar de respetar
lo que creemos que son las intenciones
del compositor era pregunto abría la
horita sería y qué hace un compositor un
compositor igualmente se relaciona
íntimamente con el sonido y no
internamente porque finalmente lo
primero que lo escuché es lo primero que
el cuerpo es el sonido hay muchas veces
que tenemos la tendencia a pensar que un
compositor está detrás de un piano con
esperando que las cosas le
y sufren la inspiración de sí abrahams
qué es la técnica sin el oficios en la
artesanía la inspiración madre de bien
poco
en ese sentido el compositor a partir de
esa imagen acústica y a través de la
técnica del oficio
y de muchas horas de trabajo irá
manipulando o desarrollando trabajando
ese sonido estirándolo comprimiéndolo a
cortándolo en definitiva irá siendo su
oficio y tratará de plasmar lo de una
manera generalmente gráfica es lo que
conocemos por una partitura una
partitura no deja ser un conjunto de
signos más o menos musicales en los que
con la que el compositor se sirve de
poder expresar sus ideas y sobre todo de
compartirlas
ahora bien queda pendiente en lo que
el punto que estábamos que estamos
tratando para qué sirve la coreografía
es extrañísima de qué hacemos qué
hacemos los directores para eso
deberíamos hablar de un principio
fundamental en la música y es donde vive
la música vive en el tiempo en el tiempo
el sonido la música no sé qué posible
en ese sentido lo que hacemos los
directores es anticipar el tiempo con
nuestro gesto
el gesto nos sirve para anticipar la
realidad acústica lo que hacemos con
esos movimientos con ese gesto es tratar
de ayudar a las maestras ya los maestros
de la orquesta para tratar de adivinar
cuándo de qué manera y quién debe tocar
en un momento determinado
m
si me permiten un director podría ser
algo así como toquemos ahora
la tensión toquemos ahora
toquemos fuerte
toquemos cada vez menos y menos y menos
fuerte
cada vez más y más más piano
maestra cuando guste
toquemos rápido
toquemos lento
toquemos sonidos cortos
los sonidos largos conectados unos con
otros
aguantemos el sonido
crezcan crezcan crezcan
detengan el sonido
como se han dado cuenta no es entraña
mayor dificultad no deja de ser un
código más o menos
un código gestual que compartimos todos
los motivos y que nos hace saber si un
director sin la directora nos pide una
cosa o bien toda la contraria es decir
no entran llamado mayor dificultad lo
que sí es verdaderamente curioso es
es que el tiempo es el que donde suceden
toda esa gestualidad antes de que ocurra
sónicamente es decir vivimos antes del
tiempo en ese sentido los director nos
dedicamos a anticipar lo que va a sonar
por supuesto también reaccionamos si
alguno de ustedes está tocando demasiado
fuerte trataré con mi gesto de que se
equipara al resto de la orquesta en el
caso de que la articulación de algunos
de ustedes alguna sección de ustedes sea
contrastante con el resto del grupo
trataré de tratar de emparejar la por
tal de que así sea pero fundamentalmente
a eso nos dedicamos los directores de
orquesta permítanme previamente regresar
regresar a los sentidos
hablando el tiempo de un cuadro
que está una fotografía
puedo tocar una tela
puedo asombrarme con el aroma de un
perfume
puedo maravillarme con el sabor de unas
gorditas de migajas o de un chinito
tapeado
pero si te dan cuenta lo que estoy
diciendo ya ha pasado
el sonido es único e irrepetible
lo que digo a medida que lo pronunció
desaparece para no volver a suceder
jamás que si gana en una conversación
con octavio paz decía borges que el
momento que hablo ya queda lejos de mí
cuando citaba por cierto agua lo la
música no puede conjugarse en presente
la música siempre es pasado
o es futuro
la música es potencia o es memoria
cuántas cosas nace
para morir en el mismo instante dice
roxana el final de cyrano de bergerac
en ese sentido ese es el otro castillo
de la música lo efímero del sonido
dígame algo si oímos desde antes de
nacer si vivimos hasta el momento los
momentos de nuestra muerte si no podemos
dejar de oír si lo que oímos se nos es
formas en los que hay de los dedos
estaremos de acuerdo en la importancia
que tiene la escucha
no creo que deberíamos ser más
conscientes de la audición no creo que
podemos ser más reflexivos más
reflexivas para ser más críticos
por entonces críticos porque por ejemplo
somos tan críticos con las películas
mostrar vídeos con el mundo del cine y
somos tan condescendientes con la música
esas películas de kubrick descubrí que
una película se trata de poner en
relación a la música y la imagen que es
eso lo que nos hace recordar una
película no recordamos las escenas no
recordamos los diálogos lo recordamos lo
que recordamos en la música en la imagen
de robert bresson aprendíamos
que un sonido puede detonar una imagen
pero difícilmente una imagen puede
detonar un
para ir acabando
les comento que si el médico
fundamentalmente la música contemporánea
la música contemporánea música clásica
contemporánea es quizás para los músicos
el peor es de los escenarios para que no
le gusta la música que no es melómano
quien no ama la música clásica pues
somos músicos clásicos para los músicos
clásicos somos aquellos que hacemos
rollitos y repertorios extra existimos
pero bueno como fue aquí es la música
contemporánea de aquí de qué hablamos
cuando hablamos de música contemporánea
un momento como saben ustedes en el que
los parámetros musicales se pusieron en
tela de juicio como otras disciplinas
artísticas ocurrió con la plástica por
ejemplo que cuestionó
el arte figurativo en favor de la
abstracción
así los compositores nos dimos cuenta
que los parámetros tradicionales de la
música el ritmo la melodía y la armonía
no eran suficientes para decir aquello
que queríamos decir
si les hablo música contemporánea
sencillamente para tratar de provocar su
escucha
para tratar de abrir un poco la audición
creo que es importante que escuchemos
creo que es importante que digamos creo
que la música es un bien precioso y
preciado para todas las personas
déjense tentar
déjense de gente dejen seducir
permitan ser seducidos por la música
sean reflexivos sean críticos
y sobre todo confronte que tengan el
valor la valentía de confrontar sus
gustos musicales quizás sólo quizás una
canción de cuna de los pigmeos del
áfrica central pueda ser más conmovedora
en algún momento que un reggaeton
quizás sólo quizás
una polifonía primitiva del siglo pueda
ser más enriquecedora que cualquiera de
los insignes ejemplos de la industria de
la música
y no tengan horror al vacío al menos al
vacío musical el silencio puede ser el
más refinado de los sonidos oigan
escuchen y sean muy felices haciéndolo
gracias por escucharme
[Aplausos]